hello everybody my name is markiplier
welcome back to let's play crime fear
recidivist the Synod if sis raised thin
amis seven Wow
no no I'm gonna bonk you so I'm on it
I'm a fist I'm gonna miss you so hard
for gonna try a lump oh what's that oh
you did just as expected all right I
handled that yo so I handled it pretty
well I I'm good under pressure
I do good in pressure situations in a
minute you're gonna feel a little
pressure
hey wha a pressure like hell
hey I know I'm referring to anyone
anyone oh my what dawn Harley oh my
say wha who the why the huh what da oh
boy
yeah this is a whole new level of freaky
wow that guy's tryin to cut off his arm
that guy did cut off his arm good for
you you're obviously do you're cutting
your leg now never on alright that's
yeah that's that's freaky good job guys
[ __ ]
and there goes nothing trap-trap I don't
trust anything
step into the fists of fury I'm gonna
murder your face murder you're ugly they
don't fall don't fall don't fall
okay oh thank you
hotly I get to save it's my dream come
true it's about damn time
all right let's see what else is good
story I don't know oh my god ray loud
and here we go I don't want to bug out
Oh something happened what happened me
there's gonna be chair gonna be a
monster you're gonna be came going me I
can't go you won't let me go it won't
you just won't let me go
hello ladies how are you doing okay so
anyway I can't get in those good for me
oh yeah this all this yeah this is good
this is good he's getting out of here
just as good as going home wrapping up
in a nice cozy blanket and just drinking
a cup of tea yeah maybe
oh boy ow my balls went into my ears
don't ask how it just happened ah
that is not a star but that's God come
on ah I got him got us our I couldn't
even say him I had a kit reload I
couldn't get through him oh I was not
expecting that by the way I was not
ready for that to happen just saying I
would've totally uh okay so I'm gonna
just get my gun out I can't see anything
without my gun oh let's catch 22 or
something oh boy here we go
Oh balls in ear uh okay
thank you thank you you're just saying
right there
hahahahahaha mark ain't no fool that's
what you get for messing with the
markiplier oh the best who the best who
the best oh and boat to be me the answer
was supposed to be me whoever you
thought of first died of fire
who says I'm better
wait was at the end of that Hall veg oh
what that chapter to escape okay if you
say so
thank you for did suggesting so nicely
but I killed myself how exactly am I
gonna is cafe I don't think I can at
this point I'm pretty sure I'm doomed
for all eternity eternity okay good yeah
yeah kebabs was a police line no way no
way a police oh don't fall don't fall
don't fall don't fall don't fall over I
don't trust any of yo yeah
juergen bro King ding full baju dena wow
this looks Funkadelic yeah you heard me
Funkadelic I'm bringing it back oh I
find out a Castiglione it on the fall
new son of a monkey fine
good golly oh thank you Oh lots of
morphine oh did I lose all my stuff I
lost all my stuff tonight
I lost oh no not again
I need a hug on boobs super shoes hmm
oh that's the good stuff I just come but
this is not the stuff about you but you
I'm like what you I can't find you I
don't have it God get your fists
equipped you do huh I can't I can't I
can't I gotta just gone gotta get rid of
the morphine Oh
what did that do oh god what happened
what just happened what just happened
did I go into super mode Oh no ha
no what happened I can't oh god oh
there's a lantern Oh ah why got out what
is going on I'm so confused
oh man ah [ __ ] now uh that was uh that
was a misjudgment there okay hang on
look right up in the arm grab that
apparently reality the rebels just
immediately and apparently uh I missed
it
that's a hard - whoa there's another
target okay well there's a target oh I
get it
amp up there we go oh I see aha so I
just need to wait until I pass around to
e it again ah no way it happens at
double intervals okay they're
oscillating or not oscillating what's
the word I don't know okay so it's right
there and three two one buck got it like
about and this will go all the way out
to here
perfect Oh who's the best jewel
I warned you last time Nick I'm talking
to you
I'm just king of random names to creep
people out or am i Molly now
specifically targeted
yeah yeah huh whoa whoa oh it's Sophie
again Sophie if that's really you lift
up your shirt it's the only way to
confirm Sami oh I was blinded by the
beauty oh no I was not I was not that is
exactly not what happened all right
yeah now the lady's supposed to pop out
now I kill her so now gasp ha watch
pound
I said pound Wow now don't jump into her
haha wow I heard I heard it her out went
into my flesh cop guy vouched I pounced
you oh whoa okay
oh here we go got it
I'm such a boss I know anybody out there
hello oh not another one
I'm just running I'm going screw it
screw it I'm not wasting their time I'm
gonna have like an army of those ladies
behind me at some point I'm going the
wrong way all right
oh yeah see this is my story in my life
I have to run away from the ladies ages
they mob me right ladies right am i
right
I mean come on just look at all look
look look at all no none of that
no no no those who have bravery in their
hearts leave their guide here yeah yes
yeah yes okay oh how its gun hose gun
wait isn't this mobile phone kind of a
guide isn't this the equivalent of
guiding isn't this also guide hahaha
well okay all right then I guess it's
not really a trade off then well I guess
if I have the shotgun out I can't really
see ah douche what are you sure lime oh
yeah boo who else won't Sean see ya what
[ __ ] up what up yeah Boop
I'll put out a shotgun when I'm good and
ready to blow someone's brains out their
face hold which I'm gonna make with my
shotgun yeah
I really know I really like this I
really like this custom campaign is
exceptionally well made lots of detail
lots of interesting use of level design
- okay I can't go that way won't even
work nup not even gonna try I'm pretty
sure Simon has just given up on any door
working so only tries half of them hello
is anybody home
yeah this looks good oh yeah I like this
so you well what's up
no that's just like the floor lighting
oh I don't have a light on my feet I
must have those killer shoes man with
the lights whenever you step they blink
yeah I still wear those alright so now I
have gun light combo no oh my god our
stuff over there there's some other I
want to go back I'm gonna go back to
shop oh no there was stuff I didn't ah
wah ha shootin Chu dad I don't know oh
cool that worked
what good hey let me use my shout gun
whatta ya Babu
yeah take that tumor uh can't you can't
find me tentacles oh man I know where
this is going
um I didn't mean to get to the last boss
yes oh yeah I am Alive I am Alive I'm
letting people in again yeah it feels
good to see Sofia once in a while uh-huh
oh sure I am reminded of what people
consider normal every time she walks
through my door yeah her eyes open to me
without the sickness of judgment it will
never feel completely alright yeah but
it has become bearable hmm so
wonderfully bearable hey thanks for
playing thank you for making it guy man
that was a really good one I'm really
really impressed with how that was made
and it came in clocked is like the first
ever customs can store campaigners story
in any or any game that's actually ended
just as soon as I wait is there anything
else here just as soon as I hit about 15
minutes I think that's it so I get back
to the menu here so thank you everybody
so much watching those are the reasons
why I love craft beer and that's why I
love team size skeller for making this
game so that people can let their
creativity just flow it's incredible I'm
glad the voice actor was able to help
out too so thank you all so much for
watching if you got suggestions for the
next one I should play write in the
comments below click the annotations for
more videos that I've done in as always
I will see you
in the next video bye-bye